Brooklyn is on YouTube how can I build
my credit history when I got my car and
they said my score was great but they
denied the loan because of a lack of
history
well Brooklyn you're asking the wrong
question you should be asking how can I
become wealthy because building your
credit history does not make you wealthy
it makes you able to buy things that you
don't have the money for to impress
people you don't even really like the
only way your credit history is built is
if you borrow money and pay it back so
that you have the opportunity to borrow
money and pay it back so that you have
the opportunity to borrow money and pay
it back FICO is the name of a dog that
chases its tail woof woof
you're borrowing money so you have an
opportunity to borrow money so you have
the opportunity to borrow money all your
FICO dog says woof woof is I just gave a
bunch of money to a bank for a number
that only means I played kissy-face with
them it does not mean you're wealthy
none of your FICO score has anything to
do with your net worth none of your FICO
score has anything to do with your 401k
balance none of your FICO score has
anything to do with having an emergency
fund none of your FICO score has
anything to do with doing a budget none
of your FICO score has anything to do
with having a paid-for house none of
your FICO score has anything to do with
your income if someone gives you ten
million dollars and you simply put the
ten million dollars in investments your
FICO score won't change one dime you're
a ten millionaire instantly when that
happens your FICO score doesn't change
one point unless you use it to pay off
debt or get into debt with
FICO scores all about interacting with
Deb so when you got your car and they
said my FICO score was great you should
have said oh god I'm sorry you shouldn't
have checked my FICO score because I'm
paying cash if the car dealer
complements your FICO score this is not
a good sign
if broke people are making fun of your
financial plan this is a good sign